frontline health workers are growing
frustrated watching covet infection
rates rise while more masks come off we
removed precautions at the very worst
time as a new wave is about to start a
lost layer of protection as another
means stalls just 47 percent of
canadians have had a booster dose we
need to get rid of this idea that being
fully or adequately vaccinated is
anything less than three that's wrong so
if you are not a three you are not
adequately vaccinated the federal
government still considers a double dose
fully vaccinated with no plans to make a
change officials are mulling
recommendations for fourth doses for
those over 50.
experts are also hanging hopes on strain
specific vaccines seeing success in
clinical trials going forward
this is going to be tied really closely
to
pathogen surveillance
instead of relying on pcr testing
provinces are tracking wastewater as
well as hospital and icu numbers it
revealed omicron's subvariant ba2 is on
the rise but severity of illness isn't
so far other countries have seen similar
trends but they're showing covit isn't
latent the who is now warning of a new
strain out of the uk
xe a recombination of omicron's ba1 and
ba2 subvariants it's believed to be 10
percent more transmissible than ba2
which is causing the latest surge
because we're giving kovitt a chance for
this to happen
the ball is no longer in our court the
ball's not on the viruses court this is
kind of a do-it-yourself pandemic if you
have any symptoms
stay away and protect other people more
reason to stay vigilant keep masks on
and minimize spread
jamie morocco global news toronto